your husband doesn't have husband
goggles he notices you aging simping is
an epidemic now what did I mean by this
now number one is this true or is it
false wait for it crickets not as do
husbands notice that women age yeah I
noticed that when men showed pictures of
their wives to me it was always a
picture from like 10 years ago they
noticed you know and this doesn't mean
this does not mean that men will leave
you high and dry that they cannot love
you for different things this does not
mean you are worthless if you age but
what it does mean is husband goggles
are not real it's just a thing that men
say to make women feel better about
getting old now and what do I what do I
mean by simping simping is telling women
what we want to hear so we can live in
delusion for a lifetime